Hey, what's up guys?
I brought you back out
to the beach again today
because I discovered a cool little trick
for turning these fibers
on a coconut husk into a bundle of rope.
It's not that difficult to do
and it's a really cool trick,
especially if you find yourself
in a survival situation.
Now after you bust your coconut open,
one of the first things
you're going to notice
is all these hairy fibers in here.
And if it's a mature coconut,
like the brown ones,
it's going to be very dry.
Now just go ahead and use your fingertips
and pull off the bits of that fluff.
We want to try
and get the finest fibers possible.
Now you can see when this first
comes out of the shell.
It's kind of dirty, grungy.
There's some hard pieces
of fibers in there.
Get rid of any of the fibers
that are a little bit too hard.
We just want to keep the fine fluffy stuff
as much as possible.
Now this is where things get really cool.
Once you got your little ball
of coconut fuzz like this,
just grab a few fibers up top.
Give it a little pinch
and start twisting it,
and as you're twisting,
give it a little tug,
and you'll find, just like magic,
it starts pulling a string right out
of the center of the fuzzy ball.
And as long as you pull and twist,
it'll keep that string going
until there's nothing left of the ball.
It's entirely consumed.
How cool is that?
So there you go. Just like that,
we got a little piece of cordage
made out of our coconut husk.
The problem is it's not very strong.
So we're going to reinforce this thing
using a reverse twist,
which isn't too difficult
once you see how it's done
Twist the cord
so you put some tension on it,
the same direction
you were twisting it before.
Then put it over,
pinch it with your thumb and finger,
and grab the one from underneath
and do the same thing.
What we're doing
is creating a reverse twist
that essentially locks
these two cords together.
It binds them so they can't come undone.
So you can see we've got a few inches
of double-stranded coconut husk rope,
which actually is impressively strong.
It takes quite a bit to break this.
Now if you want to make your rope longer,
all we have to do is
take another piece of cordage
and graft it onto the end here.
And you basically do that
by running the two fibers together,
unraveling them a little bit,
and then breaking the fibers together
and giving it a twist.
And what that essentially does,
is it grafts it into one continuous piece
like we had before.
You can see that
when the grafted parts are twisted it in,
the cord is virtually seamless.
So you can really make your rope
about as long as you want.
So check this out, guys.
I just spent about 45 minutes
on the beach,
made myself a little wristband, here,
out of some rope,
and I got about maybe four or five feet
of rope stranded out here.
Use it for a clothesline, put it
on your wrist, use it for decorations.
Maybe you could use this
for making torches, candle wicks.
You can double this up
and make it stronger.
We're going to do that same concept again,
but this time we're going
to do the opposite twist we did last time.
Before we were going clockwise,
but this time we're going
to go counterclockwise
so that it makes a nice twist,
and we're going to go underneath.
Then we're going to grab the one on top,
we're going to go counterclockwise
and go underneath.
And we're going to repeat that process
for the full length of the rope here.
What's cool about this is
I'm weaving it by hand,
but if you look closely here,
It almost looks like a legitimate rope,
doesn't it?
With the double strands in there.
There we go made it to the end.
Now we're down to about two feet of cord,
but that's quite a bit stronger.
And we can pull it
to work out some of that tension,
And then if we wanted to,
we could just repeat
that process all over again
and make it even stronger.
There we go.
So we've gone from six feet
of relatively strong rope
to about one, maybe one and a half feet,
of really strong rope.
And that is holding it really good.
I'd be curious to know how much weight
that would actually hold,
but I'd be willing to bet it'll hold
at least 100 pounds.
*Music*
So there you have it guys.
That's how to take a coconut husk
and turn it into a rope.
Any length or any thickness
you want it to be.
Thanks so much for joining me
for this experiment
and I'll be looking for you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.
[tree branch snaps]
[laughter]
Alright, well looks like
we got some firewood.
*Music*